so I'm a software too
/ but i took a rather unusual path to
to code I taught myself out of code by
making 180 websites and 180 days so I
grew up on the east coast of the United
States in a suburb of Philadelphia where
my family has lived for over 250 years
as farmers and small business owners and
while there was a lot of Duty yourself
spirit in my community there wasn't a
lot in the way of art and technology and
growing up I didn't have any role models
for what a software engineer even was so
when I went to college I ended up
studying fine art in part because it had
absolutely nothing to do with farming
but also because I was really passionate
about making things so while I was there
I ended up going to an art museum with a
friend and we were wandering the halls
we got down to the basement
we turned around a corner and we were
confronted with this an amazing
sculpture it's wrong you expand and this
the sculpture is incredible
it's a 7-foot tall hyper-realistic
sculpture of a very large dude and it's
absolutely breathtaking as soon as my
friend and I stepped into the space we
immediately dropped our voices down to a
whisper it was that powerful and I
remember thinking to myself how
unfathomable it was that this thing even
existed I mean the sheer size of this
thing
the weight the cost and especially the
amount of skill an artist would need to
build something so complicated and so
detailed and so beautiful it was an
experience I took with me all the way
through grad school so after grad school
I felt like there was this explosion of
Technology happening all around me we
have all these amazing products that are
getting made from open-source projects
like docker we have new communication
platforms like Twitter wearables
Internet of Things all these amazing
things and I realized I wasn't satisfied
with just using these products I wanted
to get out there and actually be able to
build them I wanted to learn to code now
when a lot of people think about what it
takes to learn how to code they think
I'll I have to go to some special course
and I need to take special classes and
get certification for certification and
then then I'll finally be able to make
some web apps or something
but along with this explosion and
technology has been an explosion in
information and so all the knowledge you
need is actually already out there
online and most of its free so as long
as you have a project that you want to
work on and the motivation to do it you
already have all the tools that you need
to be able to learn and grow and I love
working on self-directed projects so I
knew when I wanted to learn to code that
going through a bootcamp or an online
course just wasn't going to work for me
so when I started thinking about what a
good self-directed project would look
like I came up with a few guidelines for
myself so first I wanted to start small
I knew that I had never done any coding
before and so I wanted to take these
large coding concepts and condense them
down into something manageable something
I could tackle as a beginner - I wanted
to code something I could see I wanted
to what I was working on to result in
something tangible and so that I could
play with it and explore and then three
is I knew in order to develop the
interactive dynamic web apps I was
ultimately interested in making I would
need to develop for the full stack so
that left me with a couple of different
ideas for how to approach this first I
thought okay well why don't I take a few
small websites and just start there and
then eventually jump on to something
bigger and this was appealing in a lot
of ways because you know I didn't know
what I was doing so this would allow me
to get comfortable with tools for
building websites and also how websites
were even built but then I was left with
the nagging question of how many of
these websites would I need to make
before I moved on to something bigger
and would I ever actually feel like
moving on to something bigger so I said
okay what if I just jump right in tackle
one big app and this is appealing to to
me in a lot of ways because it would get
me right to what I was ultimately
interested in doing and a lot of people
have gone down that path themselves and
been very successful but as a beginner
this seems like a really large mountain
of knowledge to try to climb so that
left me about 1/3 crazy option which was
build 180 websites in 180 days and it
turned out this was great for me it was
in
hence immersive learning environment
that allowed me to explore any and all
ideas that I found interesting along the
way and and gave me plenty of room for
productive failure so I said all three
rules for myself first I would build one
website one website a day excuse me
one website a day every single day 480
days each website would be accompanied
by a blog post and three all of the code
that I wrote would be public publicly
published on github and so throughout
the project I was able to do a whole
bunch of different things I was able to
learn HTML CSS JavaScript Ruby on Rails
even a little bit of nodejs I was able
to make toys games tools data
visualizations even real-time
communication apps and by the end I was
able to build the dynamic interactive
web apps I'd originally set out to do so
on April 1st 2013
I made the very first website for the
project and that's the homepage now this
is just a couple of lines of HTML and
CSS and it took me all freaking day to
do so it's not much but it was a start
and so by day three I was ready to get
into some interactive JavaScript
awesomeness this is random color
background and as you can see you click
the button up the top you get a random
color background so it's a really simple
concept but I was super excited about
this because it was the first time I'd
made something that people could
actually interact with and change and
now that I had the power of JavaScript
as an arbitrary coding language I was
able to go out and explore a whole array
of coding concepts so object-oriented
programming came pretty quickly for me
this is dropping boxes this is from Dave
15 and here you can see I'm already
starting to think about these objects on
the screen as little individual beings
and so you click on them they get a CSS
animation that I coded up and I really
like this one just because the the boxes
all seem to take on their own little
individual personalities and this would
also mark the start of something of a
CSS obsession of mine at the beginning
of the project and so this is silly
kitty and this is the ultimate Express
of that CSS obsession so this is all
done with CSS there's no images on the
screen there's just a couple of
JavaScript handlers and it's 656 lines
of CSS yeah so I was super proud of it
really excited by it but I also realized
that maybe I should start thinking about
using proper JavaScript objects and so a
few days later I made little dude this
is from day 36 and he's this little
Tamagotchi guy you can feed him you can
hug him you can play with him and like
all good Tamagotchis you can kill him
and he still depends really heavily on
CSS particularly for how he looks but he
is a proper JavaScript object as
maintaining his own state and so here we
have picnic from day 126 and so this is
at this point I've got a good handle on
JavaScript objects all of these little
bugs on the screen are their own
individual objects and they're all
managing their own state on the system
and you can see that they're they're
interacting both with the mouse to try
the cursor to try Boyd getting squished
then they're also interacting with each
other and actually transferring energy
as they bump into each other across the
blanket and I got into physics for a
while so once I started working with
JavaScript objects I naturally
gravitated toward the html5 canvas
element and this is one of the things I
did during the project that I wouldn't
have necessarily done going through a
bootcamp or an online course but it was
actually really incredible because it
gave me the opportunity to use
JavaScript as an arbitrary coding
language and actually explore coding
Kandra coding concepts using javascript
so this is from Dave 55 it's called
paratroopers it's a little game where
the object is to land your paratroopers
on that island so that they can take a
vacation and I had not done any physics
to speak of since high school when I
started this project so getting those
little dudes to jump out of that plane
and fall through the air in a realistic
way was a pretty complicated task for me
it took me a while to figure out the
formulas and equations to get it to work
so I was really happy by the end of the
day that I was able to make it happen so
the next day I took a little breather
okay it's supposed to say hooray and
came back right back the next day with
bug blaster so this is a little cannon
game where we have these bugs up in the
sky and you're supposed to hit him with
this cannon and you can adjust the
parameters so this was also another
difficult physics problem for me to
tackle and it took a long time for me to
actually get the cannon to work
correctly so I didn't get to add as much
design as I wanted to but then a friend
mentioned that I've gone from basically
from 0 to 2d kinematics in two days so I
felt a little bit better about that and
this is blinky this is from day 123 and
this is based off of my favorite prices
right games link go and you can see you
drop a disc and it has to bounce off
these little pins and you're supposed to
get it into the green area and I had set
out on the day to make this unbelievably
awesome game and it was incredibly
difficult for me to actually get that
ball to bounce off of those pins
correctly so it ended up taking to the
wee hours of morning just to get it this
far so I was pretty bummed because I had
set out to do something a lot more with
this and didn't get as far as I wanted
to so I felt like kind of a failure but
in reality there were a number of
failure days throughout the project
so the first failure day comes from day
8 this is more drop shadow and I had
this vague concept of you could give
users an ability to kind of play with
the drop shadow design element and I
don't know but what ended up happening
is I started the day and I made a mock
and it made another mock-up I made
another markup and before I knew it it
was 8 o'clock at night I had nothing on
the screen and it was totally panicking
so I just quit grabbed whatever mark I
could find and this is what I came up
with and I was totally totally bummed
out about this because I hadn't executed
on my vision it's already day 8 and I'm
failing hard and like what is this crap
who might how am I gonna show this to
somebody and in reality I as much as I
was upset I didn't I hadn't failed right
I had never set out in my rules that
every website had to be great or even
good or mediocre and in fact the failure
days often came with really valuable and
interesting
so this is the San Francisco hipster
quiz and it's just a basic form and it
was super easy for me to get that up and
running but it turns out writing content
is incredibly difficult
in fact so difficult that it took me
eight hours just to write the content
for this dumb quiz and some failures are
kind of I can be kind of proud of this
is Swivl this is from day one ninety
three and it's I had this idea for a
game where you had these wedges and then
when the when you clicked on one it
would turn and then when the edge of a
wedge lined up with the edge of another
wedge then that wedge would turn it
would set off this crazy chain reaction
and there would be points and strategies
and and bells and whistles and all this
fancy stuff around it and it turns out
you might be surprised that is kind of
hard and tricky to get that system
actually working correctly so took me
several several tries over the course of
the day and at the end of the day I
didn't get to add in any of the gameplay
that I wanted so in that sense it was
kind of a failure but I still think it's
really cool that I got the system to
work and in fact it's kind of fun to
watch the system go from this chaotic
state into a lot of order and sometimes
failures can be really amazing and
interesting so I this is fireworks this
is from day 58 and I set out with the
day and I said okay I've got three main
goals that I need to hit one I got to
get that rocket to go up in the air - I
got to get the particles to explode out
and fall down the screen and then three
I got a style it make it so that those
particles kind of fade out randomly and
that the fireworks at the top are bigger
and basically just make it look like
fireworks so I started with step one
that was great I got this step two that
looked good and then I figured okay I
better you know I've got all these
particles falling off the screen and I
better you know clean them up out of the
array so I don't end up with a memory
leak blowing up my browser so I went
into did that real quick and then I came
back just to check on things and
everything was perfect it looked amazing
I had a beautiful randomly fading out
particles there was like even like these
trailers that were really cool I was
like I have no idea what's going on here
but you know what [ __ ] it ship it I'm
good to go I get a couple extra hours of
sleep
and it wasn't until later that night
that I was started thinking about it and
you know how you're not supposed to
delete items from array in place
turns out the visual representation of
that as fireworks and so I didn't lose
my artistic side during the project my
family was keeping along with me and
especially in the early days I didn't
have Attili make a website that didn't
have quite enough direction about what
you were supposed to do and my family
would very helpfully send me an email
telling me my website was broken for the
day because they were too afraid to
actually click somewhere and break
something so that's where the idea for
snare came from and this is TOS this is
the Terms of Service for Jennifer Dewalt
comm and it was it's actually been
adapted from automatics Terms of Service
for WordPress which is released under a
creative commons share-alike license and
this is electro bounce I love this one
this is from day one 96 and so we have
these nodes on the screen and they're
bouncing around and when they get close
to each other aligned forms between them
and as they move away the line
dissipates and you can change all these
parameters from the speed the distance
the color the width all these different
things and I love how you get so many
different moods and emotions and
feelings from this app so I'd love to
see this one installed in like a party
or something where people can come up
and play with it and change the way it
looks based on how the feeling of the
room is and it made a bunch of tools
during the project as well so this is
email impact and this the point of this
is to keep your help you keep your
emails concise because nobody likes
really long drawn-out boring emails and
so here as you type in words the font
actually contracts and gets smaller so
the more content you put in the harder
it is to read and this is trees for the
forest so this is a big favorite of mine
so this is from day 117 and I mentioned
that I got really into physics for a
while I also started thinking about how
things like how code reflects reality
and how math is related to code and
nature and all these crazy geeky things
and I've came to fractals I start
thinking about fractals and I remember
that as a kid when I learned to draw
trees I learned by drawing these crazy
fractal patterns so here for trees for
the forest you can actually click on the
screen and they grow these beautiful
fractal trees and add colorful leads to
them and when you have your whole scene
ready and beautiful you can actually
download it to save it for later and
then this is color work so this is a
tool that I actually needed in the
project so I built it every day I was
creating a new color palette and I
needed to very rapidly build up the
shades and the and the end of textures
and thing and colors for for what I was
working on that day for buttons and
headers and shadows and all that stuff
so I came up with this because I needed
to very quickly play with the saturation
and the lightness and darkness of colors
and this is this doesn't have I still
use actually whenever I'm whenever I'm
working on a new color palette I go to
this one and color became an interesting
theme throughout the whole project and I
I've always been interested in color but
I'm not it's not something I've ever
worked with extensively before this
project I as an artist I started out and
working with black and white photography
I tend to wear a lot of black but I
think the reason it became so important
is because color is one of the more
important tools we have as developers
for conveying our meaning and so I made
a bunch of games too this is Simon and
Simon was a really popular game back
when I was a kid and it was super cool
because it was all like electronic and
beeping noises so now I can play it
whenever I want and here's a chess
sketch this is also from kind of my
crazy CSS mind days this is all done
with CSS and I have memories of fighting
with my sister in the backseat of our
car over who's a sketch was better but
it turns out that even though I have a
background in art I've never been a very
good at chess sketch artist
and this is snake this is a really
interesting game it actually dates back
to the late 70s but didn't become
popular until the late 90s when Nokia
released a cell phone that had this game
pre-loaded on it which if anybody
remembers the late 90s that was like a
really big freaking deal and so after
making a few real-world games I decided
to try my hand at
making one of my own so this is alien
attack and this this is a game based off
of Atari games my dad had this old Atari
gaming system but I love playing with
them because the games even though the
graphics were really basic the gameplay
was really easy to get started with and
really hard to master so this is a based
off of one of those games and then when
I started using rails I started thinking
about how to connect people together I
finally had the ability to allow people
to leave like a signature or some sort
of mark that showed other people that
they had been there so I came up with
quick counter and as you can see the
buttons been clicked over three hundred
thousand times and then a few days later
I decided to see what little dude was up
to so this is make a dude and here you
can make your own little dude and give
him a name a message a color and when
he's all styled up you can submit him
and he will join the army of little
dudes on the homepage and when I say
army I mean army they're over 16,000
little dudes that have been made and
Counting and here we have the tiny notes
this is from day 80 this is totally not
a rebuff of a famous social network so
you enter in your message on the left
hand side and then it goes into the feet
on the right and of course most of the
notes that were made are just kind of
garbage going spitting out to the ethers
the internet likes to do but a lot of
people took the opportunity to actually
say something very specific to me with
the app and I got really into data so
this is weather now so you enter in your
city and it queries the world whether
online API and returns the current
weather displayed really simply and here
we have elevations this is a favorite of
mine too so you enter into cities here
we've got San Francisco and New York and
we go in and this queries the Google
Places API and gets the elevations
between the two places and then displays
it on the screen so you get a visual
representation of the terrain actually
between these two these two cities and
this is de 165 and I'm really hitting my
stride here this is this is I'm pulling
together all sorts of different concepts
that I've been working on everything
from physics to
down to data visualization even
shareability and so the way this works
is we've got different notes on the
screen those are the colored dots and
you can move them around you can add as
many as you want and then from the
center we have these pulses that are
coming out and you can add more of those
as well
and as the pulses move out they pass by
the notes and they pluck them and they
flash and so you can add all these
different things get them all styled up
and the thing I really love about this
app is that the more visual beauty you
put into the system the more audio
discord goes into it so it's a really
interesting contrast between the two
okay real fast close it up so at the end
of project I started using node.js which
gave me access to real-time data so here
we've got a bunch of hashtags on the
screen these are listening to the
Twitter streaming API and as those as
those hashtags come in they flash on the
screen and they get tallied up into a
positivity rating so you can see how
happy twitter is right now and from day
one seventy nine this is all drawl and
it's a collaborative drawing up and so
here you can join with your friends and
you can you can sketch together you can
draw messages you can mess up each
other's stuff whatever and the thing
that's always fundamentally fascinated
me about the Internet is its ability to
connect us in a way that we can share
ideas and and information in basically
real-time and I think all draw early
encapsulates that feeling for me so
those are 40 of my websites and along
with the other 140 that I made is how I
taught myself to code by making 180
websites 180 days thank you